[Music]
hey guys we're here at e3 2018 I'm
Justin and I'm joined by John Warner the
game director over at anthem to learn a
little bit more about one of the more
exciting games at EA's press conference
this year great thanks for having me
yeah so I mean day to day what do you
kind of do on the gameís game director I
know that can that can change with
different companies in different
positions yeah absolutely so it's kind
of my responsibility to make sure that
we we stay on track that we stay true to
our vision and that we're making the
best possible game that we can anthem is
definitely a departure from some of the
other things we've seen from Bioware so
that's you know a really exciting new
world to explore what's it been like
putting that together it's been an
amazing experience
I mean creating new IP is one of the
more challenging things that you can do
in your career but we have an amazing
crew and we've had plenty of time to
work through it and develop it and it's
been a great experience yeah whenever
you have new IP like I I imagine there
must be so many ideas that get tossed
around how is it that you guys land it
on the world for anthem and be like no
this is the right one this is the one we
want to turn into a full game it's
actually pretty interesting process
where we started out thinking about the
type of experience and the type of
mechanics that we really want our
players to experience and then starting
that once we kind of zero in on that we
start to think about what setting would
best facilitate that experience and then
from there we can start to build on
world lore and then from there up into a
story and Bioware is definitely some
place that's known for for building huge
worlds and having a really deep lore
system how much can you tell me about
what that world is so far well it's
really interesting anthem is a world
that's separated from Earth and in all
ways it's not a colony or anything like
that and it's a world that was left
unfinished by its gods so halfway
through the process they mysteriously
disappear and now we have a world that
has their their tools basically just
kind of littered on the surface and they
do all sorts of crazy things and bizarre
things so it's a super day
planet and it would require actually
someone to be able to have a suit of
powered arm or a javelin to be able to
go out there and explore and experience
everything in the world so these aren't
like earth explorers and this isn't the
far-reaching future this is like a
divergent evolutionary path for some
other type of being I guess yeah that's
right that's right so it's uh it's a
world that's separate from Earth that
there are humans on the planet but they
are not earthlings at that if that makes
sense and living on this incredibly
dangerous world I mean how did they how
did you grow to feel like this is a
place we want to live and colonize and
not be like we want to go to another
planet that's maybe a little bit more
pleasant well there is no there's no
space travel these these people are
indigenous to this planet and so they
have no choice this is this is the lot
that they drew this is where they live
and it is a beautiful lush planet but it
is super dangerous and those dangers are
I think one of the things that are going
to expand the way that players
experience the game and are gonna make
it different every time they go into it
is the way that I understand that right
that's exactly right
it's a very living dynamic world so
every time you go out you will
experiencing something different whether
it's because it's day or night or the
weather's changed but we have a living
breathing ecosystem so you won't always
run into the same creatures at the same
spot every time it'll be it'll be a
little bit different in traversing that
world you you get to fly around which is
obviously a dream of mine to eventually
be able to put on a suit and just fly
around everywhere but I know that's a
difficult thing to balance at any kind
of open-world game having how do you
guys approach that that freedom that a
player has while at the same time making
sure that you know you're getting them
to go to the places where you want them
to go well I think that's an interesting
point it really requires you to hold on
loosely to those points right so we've
guide you we'll put down a waypoint
marker and say yep this is kind of the
area where you want to go but give the
player the freedom to choose how they're
going to get there so what happens is
you get a bunch of really interesting
decision-making going on moment to
moment as you decide in your javelin how
am I gonna get there am i flying am i
running am i gonna try underwater it's
really up to you and it gives a real
exhilarating feeling
of freedom and empowerment in the
javelins kind of seemed like different
classes in a way but you're not locked
into those once you're playing you can
kind of switch those in between missions
it sounds like yeah that's right you
play as a pilot you're a freelancer
pilot and as a pilot you get to own many
different suits and a suit can kind of
be roughly put into a type of a class
and you can swap between them as you go
and customize loadouts for very specific
purposes or just to reflect your general
play style is there gonna be any visual
or cosmetic changes that you're able to
make so they you know you feel like you
really own that Javelin absolutely I
think it's really important that even if
you and I are both playing let's say
Ranger javelins that it's going to look
and feel really unique something that is
uniquely yours not only in its like
paint job but also different pieces that
you can put on to the suit as well so it
really will look different and so the
Ranger is one of the very specific
classes like if you could break down for
me these four different classes and like
what is it that makes each one feel
unique right so the Ranger is kind of
your your well balanced in class right
it's it's a little bit nimble it packs a
good punch and allows you to go out and
do some some really good exploration
it's very mobile it's got that jetpack
you've seen a little on so that's kind
of like the beginner class like when I
first jump into the game that'll
probably a good one to start off
absolutely absolutely the Colossus is a
little heavier you're sacrificing some
nimbleness for more armor it's got that
cool shield that comes up instead of a
dodge so you're really there to draw a
fire and to protect your squadmates
but depending on how you load it out
it's up to you right you're not locked
into a class of defender you can go out
and kind of approach that in the way
that you want to approach it the storm
is a much more mystical suit you can
think of the the power source in these
suits as you can either use it to power
gadgets and devices or you can use it to
project power externally so you notice
on the storm suit it's got these cool
seals on one arm and that allows it to
project elemental power and gives it
these great attacks and then it is
tapping into
more mysterious power of the world is
that still something that you're
grounding in in a science or do you want
it to feel very mystical and mysterious
so you wanted to feel mysterious this is
the cool thing about a science fantasy
property we don't have to explain all of
the technology that goes behind it you
can kind of give the general sense hey
these are these javelins suits they run
in this cool power source and and of
course being a part of the the EA
background
I know microtransactions loot boxes are
you know they're a big part of the
conversations but it doesn't sound like
that's gonna be a big part of what
anthem is about no it's not and in fact
from when we very first started
designing anthem back in 2013 2012 we
were really thinking of an experience
that would give our players a lot of
delight and we never factored in you
know a blind draw or loop box system
into our thinking it was always look we
want to sell you some cool things that
you're gonna love and it's all about
customizing and vanity and so thinking
about that experience that that's
something that people will get to try
out here at here at e3 or is that
playable on the show floor it's going to
be behind closed doors for right now so
a few people get to have hands-on with
it and everybody else can watch the demo
up at EA play or will be releasing a
video of it I'm sure sooner or later you
know I think NVIDIA is also one of the
guys who's partnering with you and
showing off some of the cool PC tech
that's gonna be a part of the game
absolutely yeah so the game is coming
out it's not not this year but hopefully
early in 2019 soon ish yeah February
22nd 2019 that's our release date for
Xbox one PlayStation 4 and of course the
PC do you think would ever come to
switch is that something you know I love
my switch no plans for that right now
alright well I look forward to playing
this trying it out myself and getting a
lot more experience in being a part of
this crazy anthem world that Bioware
creates awesome thanks so much for
taking the time out and chat with lately
thank you and for even more content
coming out of III this year stay tuned
to game spot calm
you